and uh yeah let's read this first story
because this is breaking
just just about in the past hour check
this out trump orders review to defund
nyc
other anarchist cities and i find the
title interesting he orders a review
because right away that sounds that
actually sounds pretty good you don't
want to just be like we're taking all
your money away because what if there's
money for like orphans
you know and probably well hold on like
the orphans shouldn't suffer because the
city is defunding their police
but if it is towards certain programs
that
aren't you know someone's immediate
health care or something then maybe it
makes sense
but then in the story they actually say
he's just ordering them to do it
so here we go they say president trump
is ordering the federal government to
begin the process of defunding new york
city
and three other cities where officials
allowed lawless protests and cut police
budgets amid rising violent crime
the post can exclusively reveal trump on
wednesday sent a five-page memo
ordering all federal agencies to send
reports to the white house office of
management and budget
that detail funds that can be redirected
new york city washington dc seattle and
portland are initial targets as trump
makes law and order
a centerpiece of his re-election
campaign after months of unrest and
violence
following the may killing of george
floyd quote my administration will not
allow federal tax dollars to fund cities
that allow themselves to deteriorate
into lawless zones
trump says in the memo which twice
mentions new york mayor bill de blasio
by name
good excellent are you where are you
from drew i'm from california
all right so but you have you spent time
in new york at all
um i've done reporting in new york and
when i did
interestingly um when the whole painting
the blm mural on the floor was happening
i was there that night and someone was
gonna do it again
right like like some patriots they were
they had all their paint cans they were
they wanted to smear it they were gonna
do it they were gonna smear it
uh but nypd one of the offers officers
came up and were like hey what are you
doing you can't do this they confiscated
it and then i
actually questioned the officer i was
like interesting where
are you getting uh your orders from and
he's like it's coming from the top i was
like de blasio
is he is is so and i said you mean to
tell me
that black lives matter could riot loot
vandalize new york
but patriots can't do the same thing and
he's like well my orders aren't coming
from me they're coming from the top i
was like de blasio and he said yes
interesting wow that's on video but
think about it yeah i mean there was
mass looting in new york
they defunded their police they got rid
of the plain clothes unit crime
violence lethal crime i should say
specifically started to skyrocket
because petty crime is going down
but lethal crime shootings with that
horrifying video i don't know if you saw
it where the dude was walking with his
four-year-old daughter
and then a car just pulls up and goes
bang and kills him and this guy's got
the nerve to be like where should which
where should we where should we allocate
our funds let's paint black lives matter
in front of trump tower because trump
sucks
yeah and then they have 27 cops guarding
that mural
dude i can't believe the cops are doing
when i was in new york reporting that
weekend
there was a like i think a week or two
before the one-year-old
little black baby was was caught in the
crossfire and was shot and killed
wow so i went to uh defend the blue
gathering right and you know all the
sjws they all showed up to counter
protest
and they were literally chanting you
know some of the defend the blue guys
were like
what about the baby what about his life
he's black what about him
and the counter protesters all the black
lives matter people were like shut up
about the baby thing already
wow i'm not surprised this is all on
camera you know people don't believe me
i document this stuff so people can see
yeah yeah it's not only hypocritical
it's evil bro like
what do you mean shut up about the baby
and and
at lives livesmatter show yeah on
twitter because
normally i pull up all the citations but
everything you say you post videos of it
you're right it's all yeah i'll cite
everything that's
video documented so let's uh it was it
was a nice little
side step to rag on de blasio a little
bit let's let's keep reading and see
what's going
on they say quote to ensure that federal
funds are neither unduly wasted nor
spent in a matter
that directly violates our government's
promise to protect life liberty and
property
it is imperative that the federal
government review the use of federal
funds by jurisdictions
that permit anarchy violence and
destruction in america's cities
i love that permit anarchy yes it's like
it's not really anarchy if you're
allowing it to happen it's just
you're not enforcing the law i guess you
can call it permitting anarchy it's a
funny way to frame it
phrase it federal agencies must detail
all federal funds provided to seattle
portland new york and dc
also within 14 days attorney general
bill barr must develop a list of
anarchist jurisdictions
that permit violence and the destruction
of property to persist
and have refused to undertake reasonable
measures to restore order
the memo does not require barr to
include the four cities possibly for
legal reasons
the memo instructs white house budget
director russ vaught to issue guidance
in 30 days from wednesday
to the heads of agencies on restricting
eligibility of or
otherwise disfavoring to the maximum
extent permitted by law
anarchist jurisdictions in the receipt
of federal grants
the amount of money impacted by trump's
order could be massive new york city for
example gets about 7 billion
a year in federal aid new york is named
because of a crime wave
as officials cut police funds the city
had 177 percent
spike in shootings in july compared to
last year the city council approved
a budget in july that cuts one billion
dollars
from the nypd six billion dollar budget
and eliminates 537 million dollars in
capital spending
the memo says that in new york city city
officials have allowed violence to spike
in light of this unconscionable rise in
violence i have offered to provide
federal law enforcement assistance but
both mayor de blasio
and governor andrew cuomo have rejected
my offer and that's true
well violence has surged arrests have
plummeted in a 28-day period during the
months of june and july
new york city arrests were down 62
percent from the same period in 20 in
2019
amidst the rising violence mayor bill de
blasio and new york city council agreed
to cut one billion dollars from the new
york police department
from their budget including by canceling
the hiring of 1163 officers
the memo also cites nypd commissioner
dermot shay's june disbandment of
plainclothes units
police officials have cited this
decision as a factor contributing to the
rise in violence
the document knocks the performance of
democratic mayors in each city
as well as state leaders quote as a
result of these state and local
government policies persistent and
outrageous acts of violence
and destruction have continued unabated
in many of america cities
such as portland seattle new york and
new york the memo says in dc mayor
mayor muriel bowser allowed rioters and
anarchists to engage in violence and
destruction in late may
and early june requiring me to call in
the national guard to maintain law and
order in the nation's capital
the memo in in works uh in the works for
weeks
does not directly reference reference
activists confronting guests of trump's
rnc speech as they left the white house
probably because it was being put
together a while ago this is this is
fairly long so i'll just read the
conclusion
they say a senior administration
official told the post taxpayers
shouldn't foot the bill
for local politicians dereliction of
duty and president trump is ensuring
taxpayer dollars are not wasted by
lawless mayors
the list of cities and possibly states
will be updated periodically
with input from the justice department
the official said and federal agencies
will be directed to revise grant
conditions when applicable to upload
uphold the rule of law the official said
portland the smallest city on the list
got more than 252 million dollars in
federal funds in fiscal 2019 including
for police operations well you've uh
you've been
on the ground in many of these cities
right let me highlight this real quick
that last sentence the official said
portland
the smallest city on the list got more
than 252 million
federal funds in fiscal 2019
at the press conference the other day
the police chief in portland made it
very clear
that they are being exhausted of their
resources
that's questionable how is how is it
that they're receiving 252 million
dollars
but the police bureau in portland is
being exhausted of their resources i
don't
i don't blame the police i don't blame
the police chief
ted wheeler these governors that are in
positions of power
that designate and delegate this kind of
money
it doesn't add up this is why the
investigation is taking place because
and i've said this on i've said this on
air different podcasts tim
people have asked me and they've
questioned me drew so what do you what
do you think we do
uh what what's the answer to this and
i'm like investigations need to take
place
you're saying that someone's taking that
money no i believe
that there are elected officials that
are working
with antifa working with different
organizations in these cities that's why
they're labeling them as anarchists
and somehow dishing money to fund these
people well that's
but you think that i'm almost positive
i'll pull this story up
yeah quote i am antifa could be
portland's next mayor okay well so i'm
pretty sure it is
i think you're right the uh the city
councilman in seattle led the protesters
to the homes of other politicians and
the mayor herself
it was it was a city councilman other
council members homes and the mayor
and they all got really really mad about
it yeah there are politicians that
actively work with the funding thing i
don't know because
it's it's not expensive to be a um
i don't know a destructive [ __ ] running
around smashing things it's actually
quite cheap
you find a rock you throw it that's what
they do you know as for politicians
actively being engaged in this behavior
quite literally yes yes we watch it
happen all the time yeah
so but i will point out as it goes with
the 252 million
i mean the portland police have been at
what every single night for three months
that's a lot of overtime it's a lot of
medical bills equipments all that stuff
yeah i gotta imagine that's expensive
yeah exactly i don't know about 252
million dollars though that's what i'm
saying man that's how
they are exhausted i have families uh of
the ppb
that reach out to me there there you
know families of police officers that
the horror stories
are insane like what give us some what's
going on one family reached out to me
and let me know that um
their family a police officer's family
was doxed
and that can only happen if an elected
official
or some insiders in the government
release
this is private information you can't
get police officers
home addresses or anything like that and
antifa has showed up to their house
and threatened their children in their
front yard are these are these the
like the um tactical officers who come
out for the riots
uh no these are these are stationed in
portland not dhs
i mean that's what i mean though so like
when the when the riot cops come out
they don't have do they have badge
numbers and badges or their names
sometimes they do i'm not quite too sure
because sometimes they do cover them
because if if it right i know that with
the feds that came out they had
identifiers like you know nz1 was one of
them
i think it was nz or something like that
that you can't dox
but if i if if i see your name and i see
your badge number
then it's gonna be really easy to find
out everything about you yeah
everything so that's why i'm curious
like a lot i think this specific family
isn't actually on the lines they're not
doing riot
yeah they're not doing riot work
interesting yeah i mean i got to tell
you man the way
ted wheeler acts and the way he look the
the attorney general in oregon
sued to defend the rioters yeah the
portland d.a is friends with andiva
right well he did an interview
apparently like so so somebody somebody
tweeted out that the da himself is is
like a far left guy who's friends with
these people
because he had done an interview where
he mentioned that once he's elected
he's gonna totally you know what do they
call it restorative justice or whatever
and what does that mean restorative
justice it could mean anything these
days
it's just whatever their definition is
it could be restorative justice
according to an anarchist or a communist
that's a whole another definition so you
gotta kind of know in context what these
people are talking about well
what they said and i think this was the
veritas videos the undercover videos
from the bernie sanders staffers
it's sending people to a gulag to break
rocks so they learn what it means to do
hard work there you go
it's funny because these people haven't
done a hard day's work in their lives
most of these people i i don't know tell
me if you think i'm wrong
i don't think many of these anti-people
have lifted a heavy object in their life
i'm exaggerating a little bit but you
know what i'm trying to say right
what's your opinion on that i mean a lot
of these people they're just a lot of
soy boys
you know like i'm not i'm not that's not
derogatory i'm being honest uh
every now and then i'll see an antifa
dude out there that is kind of fit
but they they are bold in their numbers
like some exactly
some police officers uh that i've talked
to
um they've told me anytime they get
arrested like these kids are just so
bold on the street they're just in their
face they're cussing they're going
insane but
when they get arrested when they're with
the police just
zip they're like these little church
kids we gotta we gotta talk about but i
do wanna
i don't wanna do it i wanna talk i'll
ask you a couple more questions about
the fun that exists
we gotta we got a really funny story to
talk about in terms of antifa curling up
into a fetal fetal position
but i do want to ask you uh how many
cities have you been to so far with all
the writing from antifa
man all of them kenosha seattle chaz
um new york uh dc
some stuff the
do you think that like is trump right to
say
that the the cities the governments are
kind of
allowing this or exacerbating it or just
not doing their jobs oh 100
especially in portland i mean for sure
100 because the police are trained
they're trained to be able to put a stop
to all of this stuff
but their hands are tied they're ordered
not to use
the kind of excessive force that they're
trained to use against anarchy
hold on excessive force they're trained
to use appropriate force and they're
told they can't use
appropriate force yeah yeah the
excessive force thing i think
you know that's that's that's antifa
will argue that any force against them
is excessive
but like dude if you're throwing
multiples of cocktails and a cop
pushes you and then you're you're
cementing
the police precinct door with people
inside of it
yeah throwing molotov cocktails and you
know the police are going to have to use
that was seattle right yeah that was
seattle man
the mayor of portland said that they
were trying to kill people that
when they they barricaded the the back
in the front of the i think
i don't know they're trying to kill him
they were literally lighting the base of
his condo on
fire the other night he's he's moved he
apologized to the residences around did
you guys yeah yeah
he's like i'm so sorry this has nothing
to do with you guys uh you know or
politics or anything i'm like what are
you talking about these are your
constituents you were elected to protect
these people he could he could have him
he's a police commissioner isn't he
can he just have him arrested well i
guess the problem is the d.a
yep so you know what you know what
mistake he made though you know what he
said in the press conference a couple
days ago
when he was coming down on trump he said
i would something to
around the lines of i would die for a
trump supporter to be able to protest
peacefully in front of my house
those are some fighting words wow you
know the proud boys are having those are
some fighting
i remember that you hear the proud boys
are heading up there was it september
26th i think
24th somewhere around there i think it's
a bad idea
yeah i respect people's rights to people
peacefully protest so far be it for me
to tell anybody what they can or can't
do but it's gonna be
they're gonna get probably a million
hours of footage
of right-wing extremists yeah every
angle
there will be like a dude will it's like
the ryan long joke where uh i don't know
have you ever seen ryan long's comedy
videos uh i've seen a couple
he did one where it's how do you sell
footage to fox and cnn
and one of his jokes is that he
accidentally sent footage of
young black men picking up garbage to
fox news and they're like what are we
supposed to do with this and he goes you
can play it backwards it looks like
they're littering
it's a good it's a great joke he's
hilarious but that's the kind of stuff i
mean
it's a joke but yeah you'll get a video
of one of these proud boys like
flicking a cigarette into a trash bin
and then they'll freeze frame it with
his middle finger up saying he's
flicking off residence you know what i
mean they'll just like they'll go nuts
with it
yeah but hey man people have a right to
peacefully protest i just think auntie
was going to show up start a fight
and then the journalists are not going
to be aiming the cameras in antifa yep
they're going to be aiming the cameras
at the proud boys yeah they have their
own designated media the streamers
they're all designated you know they
claim to be centrists they claim to be
down the middle but
they're not they're they're absolutely
not when i when i used to do
live streaming like when i first started
doing streaming back at by wall street
i got physically threatened they came up
to me and they said from now on you only
film
the police you don't film what we do and
i said i'm going to film everybody and
they were like if you do that we will
stop you
and that's the moment tim paul became a
right-wing extremist
i mean the funny thing is kind of yeah
sure but
but no but so this is 2011. yeah oh no
the the core of the activists that
occupy wall street
opposed what what people were just
referring to as the black bloc
extremists
or the black black black anarchists
there were a handful of them that had
influence
in in the protests but most people were
like tim we love what you do keep doing
it don't stop
and it was really interesting to see
then when i went to the deplorable
when trump got elected some people
walked up to me and they were maga hats
and they were like hey we're big fans
we've been big fans since occupy wall
street and i was like
since occupy wall street like but you're
here trump deplorable like you're
wearing maga hats and they're like oh
yeah yeah we used to be big you know
uh democrats and sport bernie and now
we're voting for trump and all that
stuff
and i saw a lot of that the people a lot
of the people that i met back in the day
who were active with occupy wall street
not all of them a decent amount
always hated the violence the violence
it undermined what they were trying to
do because they had a pop
like you know taking that space and
getting the press attention they did was
helping them
and then as soon as the violent people
came in and started smashing things and
attacking people it undermined
what they were trying to accomplish now
i see a lot of those people are voting
for trump
yeah and the crazy thing is man i have a
friend and i love it when
when the left thinks it's always a lie
like it's being made up and i'm like
dude
what's the why would i tell these
stories just make them up it's the
stupidest thing ever
i i met someone at in ferguson who had a
black lives matter protest hated trump
2016 hated trump 2017 hated trump
2018 2019 hated trump 2020
loves trump wow yeah and you know it's
the human trafficking issue
because like you get the marshals
announcing they're they're catching
these these criminals and saving these
kids
and a lot of people are saying i don't
care about anything else trump you know
he's sending out the feds and they're
they're catching these traffickers and
like the arrests are going way up
but anyway yeah have you uh we'll we'll
jump over to the crying baby
crybaby antifa in the fetal position but
but notice people
i don't think you realized him what you
mean what you
mean to a lot of people you know i'm
just dude especially after
when you were on with rogan and jack
dorsey and that
i don't think you realized him and and i
know you want to be humble about it
but that that that that podcast bro
like i felt like i was watching like the
ufc
i know i'm not being dead serious i'm
being like joe rogan's right there
commentating anything
i felt like i was watching the ufc like
there are so many things
that people have been wanting to say
that you said and i just i just want to
let you know man like
you mean so much to the culture right
now it's it's it you literally bro
you're like
you were like it was like zelda right it
was literally like
zelda bro like you like the final boss
of the game like you're
you're going to work you're going one on
one with ganondorf right and like
you're like the hero of time is that's a
crazy you are the hero of time bro tim
poole
all right well i appreciate it so many
people left and right they they
because of that they love you because of
that man i appreciate that
you know it's crazy it is a crazy story
it all came together i think
i think joe had this long plan that i
had no idea what was going on
like he knew he knew what he was
planning on doing he was putting the
pieces together
i didn't until one until like at the
last minute he's like hey bro
you want to come on and i was like i
told him i i literally said to him i was
like bro i'm like a baby bird and that's
kicking me out trying to see if i can
fly man i don't know if i literally said
that i'm like well you flew bro
and yeah and and so blue you soared bro
i i just
look i was like i just do my thing right
so you can say stuff
i just sit in a room and i i yell at a
camera all day you know i just do my
thing
so my favorite part about that was that
tim did not graduate high school and he
was up against the single best
lawyer that money can buy and he pretty
much owned her and was she said
that's a compliment for her hitting the
twitter lawyer seriously
that's what i'm saying that what that
what that interview meant to a lot of
people
you just maybe you're not even aware of
how much probably not people
because i'm just sitting in a room and i
was like i'm gonna i'm gonna tell them
what for you know what i mean yeah
and that's just epic but but i mean even
after that there were things that uh
i was like i forgot to bring this up i
forgot to bring this up i forgot to
bring this up
it was sufficient man i'm telling you it
was like watching ufc joe rogan's right
there commentating
perfect i was rooting you on he's got
millions of people where his life i
think
that beer i think he's got to do i think
joe should do more of these crossfire
style
yeah shows yeah because uh i mean it
used to be a big thing on
uh who who who did the cnn was it cnn or
fox news crossfire yeah
yeah i think it was cnn you know what
crossfire was yeah
they got rid of it but it was like a
liberal conservative and they would like
talk great yeah it was probably it was a
really good idea and jon stewart like
ragged on it anyway thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you